Master Chief, the Covenant, and even energy
swords get time to shine in the series premiere
of "Halo," but a mysterious relic of unknown
origin might be the episode's most important
thing.
Warning: spoilers ahead for "Halo" episode
1.
"Humanity's best weapon."
After years spent in development, the official
"Halo" TV series is finally here!
The first entry in the series introduces audiences
to the world of "Halo" through the eyes of
Kwan Ha, a 16-year-old girl whose home planet
is attacked by Covenant forces.
Although we spend most of the first hour with
Kwan and Spartan super soldier Master Chief,
the first chapter is also chock-full of detail
when it comes to the political affairs of
the "Halo" universe and the scientific research
of Dr. Catherine Halsey of the United Nations
Space Command.
The first episode undeniably throws a lot
of exposition at both "Halo" video game veterans
and franchise newbies, so it's understandable
that some may be a little confused at the
end of the first hour.
Luckily, if you've got a question about where
"Halo" Episode 1 leaves things, you've come
to the right place.
Of course, one of the biggest questions many
fans have been asking about the "Halo" TV
series is the same question that has also
long haunted the video game franchise.
Will we see Master Chief's face?
While the video game version of the character
has yet to reveal a complete view of what
lies underneath his helmet, the television
series is already taking a different approach.
For the first 50 minutes of the nearly 57-minutes-long
episode, Master Chief is only ever seen with
his helmet securely fastened to the rest of
his tactical uniform.
Regardless of whether the warrior is in the
middle of a battle or relaxing in a spaceship,
Master Chief's helmet seems to be as much
a part of him as any other body part.
It ultimately takes a big moment in the episode
for the legendary Spartan to bare his face.
In the climax of the pilot episode, Master
Chief removes his helmet during a confrontation
with Kwan, a recently orphaned 16-year-old
girl and the sole survivor of a Covenant attack
on Madrigal.
Although Kwan holds Master Chief at gunpoint,
he confidently points out that the caliber
of ammunition in her rifle wouldn't even manage
to dent his specially designed armor.
In order to prove his loyalty to her, Master
Chief slowly lifts his helmet off his head,
leaving himself more vulnerable to attack
than we've ever seen before.
"If you want me dead, you'll need to aim up
here."
Luckily for both of them, Kwan quickly decides
that Master Chief is better as an ally.
One of the mysteries at the core of the series
so far focuses on a Covenant relic that seems
to be uniquely tied to Master Chief.
When the super soldier first makes physical
contact with the device, a bright light emerges,
surprising Master Chief's fellow Spartans
and a nearby member of the Covenant.
Even more surprisingly, however, the device
appears to trigger old memories in Master
Chief's head.
While this trip down memory lane is visibly
noteworthy to the Spartan, it isn't until
much later in the episode that the device's
true potential is revealed.
For reasons he is unable to fully explain,
Master Chief subsequently refuses a UNSC order
to execute Kwan.
Realizing that a return to Reach would mean
a certain death sentence for his new traveling
companion, Master Chief scrambles at the last
minute to redirect his ship, but only manages
to deactivate the autopilot mere seconds before
landing.
In response, the UNSC fires an electromagnetic
pulse at his ship, immediately grounding it.
When all looks to be surely doomed, Master
Chief simply reaches out to the relic, triggering
a flurry of new memories, including what looks
to be a child's drawing of the very same device.
More importantly, however, the device quickly
powers up the recently disabled ship, allowing
the duo to escape.
Obviously, this raises a number of important
questions.
What is the purpose of the device and who
made it?
So far, a Covenant human named Makee is the
only person other than Master Chief who is
able to bring it to life, obviously something
which suggests a prior relationship of some
sort between the two.
Perhaps learning more about the origins of
this show's protagonist will also eventually
provide answers about this mysterious relic.
Eagle-eyed viewers will notice that while
most members of the UNSC are quite unhappy
to see Master Chief's spaceship depart as
abruptly as it arrived, a smile appears on
the lips of the Spartan program leader in
the final moments of the episode.
So, why is Halsey smiling while her multi-billion
dollar super soldier flies away with a rebel?
We think it probably has something to do with
the influence the Covenant relic is having
on Master Chief.
"I think he's having memories."
Although Halsey is visibly astonished at the
device's capabilities, she never seems especially
eager to see other members of the UNSC get
their hands on the device.
While she admits to being somewhat worried
that Master Chief unlocking his suppressed
memories could produce unexpected results,
she actually does her best to cover for him
when he initially begins acting out.
Notably, Halsey is also rather quick to suggest
solving this problem via the implementation
of something called "Cortana," a name that
all "Halo" video game fans everywhere will
surely recognize.
Although she is obviously unwilling to voice
it right now, it also remains possible that
Halsey has ulterior motives of some form.
In the "Halo" video games, Halsey is extremely
dedicated to the members of her Spartan program,
especially Master Chief.
While it remains to be seen if the TV version
of Halsey would ever be willing to choose
Master Chief over the UNSC, it certainly seems
like something that will be a point of contention
moving forward.
New episodes of "Halo" drop on Paramount+
every Thursday.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.